something i talk about a lot on my
channel
is the existential threat that white
supremacists
play in america the threat that they
pose
tucker carlson being chief among them
i rather
famously if i was famous
i call him a lot of little cute names a
little pet names
and i really do believe he is a a
googly-eyed feather duster he has a
haircut he is a trust fund goon he is a
soft-skinned
smooth-brained clown but he also holds a
position within the american zeitgeist
that is
is uh undeniable
he hosts the the most popular cable news
show in all
of cable news history
the most popular show on fox news right
now by far and they're most popular ever
hannity's ratings don't hold a candle to
tucker carlson's
bill o'reilly in his heyday
nowhere near tucker carlson's and they
keep him around even though he is just
draining
on their budgets because who advertises
for tucker carlson no blue chip
companies up until a few weeks ago it
was just
the my pillow guy
and a few others
but tucker carlson
is advancing he has tossed away the dog
whistle and he is advancing the
conspiracy theory the racist conspiracy
theory of the great replacement theory
of white genocide
which used to be
talked about only in
literal white supremacist circles like
at neo-nazi camps and uh
aryan nation up in northern idaho
on my home state
and
he has taken it to prime time he has
taken it to the morning shows which is
what i want to talk about today he went
on fox news
fox fox and friends you know the friends
over at fox and friends
and was extolling the virtues
of the great replacement theory and
believes in a conspiratorial fashion
that joe biden is trying to destroy
these are his words destroy the country
by changing the demographics of america
watch this
yeah i mean
the you know what this tells you
honestly that what's happening at the
border is not a crisis a crisis is a
flood in bangladesh it's an act of god
this is an intentional act
this is the administration bringing
felons violent criminals into our
country on purpose
why would you do something like that
only to destroy it i mean there's
there's there's no other explanation for
this it's not an act of compassion it's
an act of hostility against the united
states in order to change it forever i
think this is the greatest scandal of my
lifetime what's happening on the border
right now well absolutely although
you've heard secretary marcus tucker
says the strategy is working which makes
you wonder what is the strategy right
well the strategy is to change the
demographics of the country now when you
say that they have a heart attack and
they call you names but they say it out
loud
i mean they say it on the floor of the
senate dick durbin did two weeks ago
this country is changing in a way that
benefits the democratic party more
democratic voters there's no other
upside in this policy by the way it
doesn't help the people coming from
around the world there's a humanitarian
disaster unfolding thanks to the bite
administration the only beneficiaries
are the people who run the democratic
party and this is an effort to change
the country and we should be honest
about it and not be bullied into silence
as they take our country away and import
violent criminals what there is a lot
there
there's a lot there to be sure
uh
not only
are is joe biden and this administration
purposefully
trying to destroy the country
this is the greatest scandal in his
lifetime
these republicans are using a lot of
this hyperbolic language surrounding joe
biden that it's the worst of this the
greatest crime this is the
the greatest scandal of all the scandals
of america
in the course of tucker's 50 years on
the planet there are many this isn't
even a scandal
but in order to whip his audience into a
frenzy and the the the larger fox news
audience since he's on fox and friends
he has to use this kind of language
but to rattle on about changing
demographics it really does put
everything in perspective
during donald trump's campaign there was
a lot of analysis around make america
great again
the campaign slogan
and the question was asked well when
when was this moment that they hearkened
back to and it's it's certainly pre-1950
when schools and american life was
segregated
they oh they pine for these these these
nuggets of history this is when they
believed america was great
when white dominance in this country was
absolutely unchecked
and that is the time for which tucker
carlson yearns he wants that again and
the fact that the country's demographics
are naturally changing when you're a
beacon of light and a beacon of hope to
the world as the republicans have
yammered on about for years
that's what you get people come here for
a better situation a better life
for themselves
and their posterity
but that scares
tucker carlson
and he is intending to scare
an audience filled with people
who also yearn for those times
interesting though that he he has a
critique about the word crisis and then
at the very end there
this was a humanitarian
disaster
he wanted so badly to say crisis but he
couldn't because he just pooh-poohed the
word
and then of course the the refrain about
taking our
country
away
whose country tucker
is it not also my country
is it not also people of color their
country
it this is no longer
safely a white
country
the the the melting pot meme has really
been overused
but it is because it is what we are we
are a diverse country
diverse culturally
diverse ethnically diverse racially
diverse ideologically
and there are certain
ideas that are no longer welcome
white supremacy being among them tucker
carlson
maybe it is you who is trying to take
away our
country